ladies and gentleman en cette journée de
canicule je vous embrasse bien fort se
donne beaucoup de courage et je vais
vous parler du haut pour hainaut avec le
zoom x 10 je vous en ai déjà parlé le
jour on a déjà fait le test pour la
partie photo vidéo
aujourd'hui on va consacrer vraiment sur
la partie hardware performance à qui se
destine ce smartphone au delà de la
partie photo bien évidemment ce qu'on
peut faire le tour complet
la compagne de seal ça mais bon on
voulait pas comme aujourd'hui on est
dans une journée de canicule il faut
boire non donc je bois et je vous invite
à boire
voilà comme ça vous resterez enviable
plus longtemps c'est quand même bien de
s'hydrater bull crashed europe donc un
smartphone qui est vachement bien je
vais détailler tous les points vous dire
ce que j'en pense ce que j'aime ce que
j'aime pas ce qui va ce qui va bien par
rapport à la concurrence pensent que oui
vous vous en douterez il ya une
concurrence en face
[Musique]
l'écran est bien d'un écran de 6 pouces
avec résolution de 2340 par 1080 pixels
à 387 pixels par pouce d'un écran amoled
à molette micro amoled plus dur à dire
en écran amoled dont la surface de
l'écran occupe 93,1 pour être très
précis la face avant on a un candidat
glace si ce smartphone résistance c'est
cool on a une certification protection
pour les yeux contre la lumière bleue
donc un vrai beau travail qui est fait
là dessus un très bel écran tout le fait
de pas voir d'encoches justement n'ayant
cette petite caméra et certaines autres
cas c'est vachement bien se donne un
très bel écran et ça c'est aussi un
point qui est très positif malgré tout
pour voir qu'on est quasiment dans le
même prix que le one + 7 pro et bien il
ya quand même différent ce soit loin de
plus cette pro vous avez un écran 3120
par 1440 pixels c'est du quad hd + à 516
pixels par pouce autant dire que le one
+ 7 points 3 759 euros sera bien
meilleure au niveau de la qualité
l'écran que ce que vous allez avoir sur
le haut pourrait nous être le zoom x 10
à 799 euros
alors bon on pourrait se dire c'est du
point de détail s'est pas complètement
faux c'est vrai que ce n'est pas
forcément les mêmes smartphone celui là
sera meilleure en photo par rapport à ce
que vous allez voir sur le site pro ils
ont chacun leurs points positifs et
leurs points négatifs mais c'est vrai
que dans cette gamme de prix c'est très
clairement pas celui là qui avoir le
meilleur écran même si l'écran malgré
tout restent de bonne qualité à côté de
ça je vous rassure l'expérience sans
tain de visionnage de gaming de tout ce
que vous voulez sur cet écran mam est
vraiment sympa à l'écran est de bonne
qualité
là je ne crois pas vraiment fiche
technique par fiche technique je mets
deux produits façon sensiblement dans la
même gamme de prix parce que lorsque
consommateur à faire son choix il va
comparer les deux produits
l'accompagnait les fiches techniques de
pense que vous comparez on a quand même
une différence entre les deux produits
à côté de ça une fois de plus le haut
forez nozuka 10 et très bien aucun dieu
vous avez des hauts parleurs haut
parleurs se situent les suit et un
haut-parleur ici de tout ce qui alors
qu'on pourrait reprocher c'est de
ramener une différence en termes de
qualité sonore si je bouge celui là
voyez il ya tout de suite beaucoup moins
de son et c'est vrai que quand même
l'expérience sonore est vachement moins
agréable il ya un vrai déséquilibre
là vous avez beaucoup de puissance là
vous avez moins de puissance sur ce haut
parleur là vous avez info qu'un un peu
plus son médium là on inspecte un peu
plus large on n'est pas sur la meilleure
qualité aux jo c'est quand même bien que
celui là en renfort
mais c'est vrai que pour une expérience
de pelures visionnage directement avec
le parleur il ya quand même un certain
équilibre à côté de ça si vous voulez
écouter au casque parce que vous êtes
absolument aucune prise jack
ça marchera bien il faut un casque
bluetooth et la vrai pouvoir profiter
d'un son dolby atmos qui sera nettement
supérieure vient de poisson qu'elle par
contre il est tout particulièrement
excellent ses côtés performances
snapdragon 855 c'est ce qui se fait de
mieux aujourd'hui qu'en termes de
performance tout ça avec 8 gigas de ram
qui lui a pas vraiment de la fluidité et
vous avez du stockage 256 giga de
stockage c'est le stockage en huile fs
2.1 et il ya vraiment tout cas été mis
en avant c'est la party gaming vous avez
un espace de jeux vous avez lu d'un
boost 2.0 vous avez le freymuth enfin
l'idée derrière tout ça si vous voulez
c'est de vous apporter une expérience
complètement fluide l'espace de jeu va
vous permettre de choisir si vous voulez
recevoir des appels par soir des appels
améliorer l'expérience améliorer
l'affichage qui sont complètement
optimisé par rapport à votre jeu et
c'est vrai que ça marche plutôt bien et
en plus de ça il ya un autre kit
bassement bien c'est le refroidissement
vous avez une triple solutions de
refroidissement
première solution sepa rosel nous avons
un gel qui va se diffuser à tarière
qu'ils n'ont creux froide d'hier le
smartphone en plus vous avez une triple
couche de gras fille dont on va parler
de quotas plus technique de graphiques
mais ça contribue refroidissement de
smartphones et enfin vous avez des
tuyaux de cuivre voilà tout ça mis
bout-à-bout fait que votre smartphone ne
chauffe pas lors de longues périodes de
gaming en tout cas les sensations que
peut avoir sont complètement maîtrisé
c'est correct c'est bien c'est agréable
et ça bravo pour les séances de gaming
badji très clairement je trouve que
c'est vachement bien ça rame absolument
pas il a absolument aucun lag ça c'est
vraiment vraiment hyper hyper
appréciable on va tout la puissance
variable sa dragonne 855 couplet 8 gigas
de ram tous tout l'optimisation derrière
que vous avez d'un point de vue logiciel
ce qui fait de cette machine vraiment
optimisé pour gainey en plus à notre
poids qu'il vachement bien c'est que
vous avez de la voûte sharks 3.0 pour
recharger votre batterie très rapidement
vous avez batterie de 4000 65 milliards
erreur c'est très gros c'est bien ça
vous donne une très belle autonomie de
la recherche très rapide vous la gardez
un jour et demi deux jours ça dépend une
fois de plus de vos usages mais de ce
point de vue là aussi c'est pareil un
vrai beau savoir faire de la part de au
pot vous êtes donc tranquille toute la
partie photo j'en ai déjà parlé lorsque
je vous ai fait mon test à roland garros
et au hellfest pour la partie nuit bon
c'est très bon il est très très très bon
site de ce point de vue là nous allons
plus un gps bi fréquence kia du nfc du
goût
tous trois dauphins dans un smartphone
qui est complet et précis qui est bien
et il compte bien évidemment sur un col
hors os6 tout nouveau s ii au pot était
basé sur l'android 9 paille pour tout
vous dire une ce smartphone je trouve
bien je trouve ça un beau travail de
fait de la part de opole une belle
montée en gamme le haut pour renault et
bien le port et n'osent une fois 10 et
nettement au dessus c'est vraiment autre
chose
799 euros je trouve bien mais je trouve
peut-être un petit peu cher vu ce qu'on
peut trouver à la concurrence je trouve
bien positionné par rapport au p 30 pro
il sera un peu moins mots en photo au
niveau traitement logiciel on va aller
un peu moins loin que ce que peut faire
un mois où elle est reçue
néanmoins il n'a pas à rougir son
nouveau choix matériels traitement
logiciel se au port et 9 à 10 et bien je
trouve un peu moins bien positionné par
rapport aux en plus cette pro qui va
être meilleur au niveau de l'écran qui
aura un meilleur son empreinte en photo
sera un peu moins bons fera un peu moins
de choses bien que la qualité photo sont
améliorées sur le wan plus être au moins
15 ans toman chose que vous pouvez faire
avec cette au port et nos zones fois
glisse avec malice que zoom x 60 mais si
vous avez regardé la vidéo de test sur
la partie photo vous savez pertinemment
que le vote 60 ans apporte pas grand
chose si ce n'est un peu l'effet what
the fuck
à côté de ça je trouve parade si vous
cherchez un smartphone qui soit très
bien équilibrée en termes de qualité
photo avec un bon écran avec une
expérience denim bien avec de la
performance ce smartphone là est
vraiment bien je vous conseille de
l'utiliser avec un casque bluetooth
ça vous a vraiment profité d'une
meilleure qualité audio avec le dolby
atmos derrière voila voila moi ce que ce
que ce que j'en pense
voilà qu'ils destinent si par contre
vous voulez vraiment profiter du
meilleur au niveau de l'écran fera
peut-être nouvelle + 7 % auxquels il
faudra aller sur les portes et du
meilleur au niveau de la photo c'est
peut-être le 30 pro sur lequel il faut
aller celui ci est un bon compromis
situe un peu entre les deux et c'est
pour moi une bonne machine à vous de me
dire maintenant ce que vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire est ce qu'il vous
plaît
est ce que vous l'avez est ce que vous
l'avez acheté est ce que vous l'avez
essayé est-ce que vous avez le bon prono
est ce que vous
voilà est-ce que vous tous apparaissent
que vous tout ça en bas en commentaire
vous marquez tout ça bien évidemment à
vous abonner
on a plein d'autres tests qui arrive
plein de choses et une grosse actu qui
va arriver à partir du mois de septembre
si sur la rentrée vous n'allez pas voir
plein de choses qui vont se passer plein
de nouveautés d'apple surprise va y
avoir du live ya pas mal de choses on en
reparlera ultérieurement par contre peut
vous abonner dès maintenant s'ils
voulaient tout savoir sur ce je fais des
robes est dégroupé doute vous embrasse
et je vous dis à demain
ciao